déjà vous enlevez le vous enlevez
enlever votre père est ce qu'il ya dans
la caméra non monsieur il ya dans la
caméra grandes escales dans la caméra
enlever c'est yann la caméra vient dans
la caméra tout vous n'êtes que devant la
caméra
non mais je ne peux pas le cas dans la
caméra ne tient pas merci francis est là
merci à sa merci francis alors on cite
déjà j'ai envie de savoir dans quel état
se trouve actuellement est ce que voilà
ce que je vois je je je sais pas ce que
tu es heureux est ce que tu es bien est
ce que tu dis je regrette ce que j'ai
fait là ou bien est ce que tu peux nous
parler de ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce
qu'il ya plusieurs questions dans ta
question est ce que je regrette ce que
j'ai fait là j'ai rien fait l'a donc je
regrette un annuaire des sables à
montfranc système suite est-ce que je
suis heureux je pense que j'ai jamais
été aussi heureux de ma vie
bon si j'ai une femme que j'aime
profondément kim aime profondément j'ai
une petite fille qui a 18 mois et après
il ya bien évidemment tout ce qui se
passe dans la société et qui bien
évidemment m'affecte comme ça affecte
beaucoup de monde j'ai décidé de
l'affronter ça et au lieu de le subir
j'ai ce que tu dis francis quand les
gens disent quand j'ai vu voilà qui
avait attaqué jean paul hamon un médecin
qui était venu nous voir ici aussi parce
qu'il avait traité d'abruti quand tu dis
quand tu vois que les gens se disent
francis il peut être dangereux parce que
il est très écouté il ya plein de gens
qui sont fans de lui et que il peut être
dangereux
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que tu dis assez
loin tu l'as entendu ça je pense que la
vérité n'est pas dangereuse et chercher
la vérité c'est c'est quelque chose qui
est plutôt salutaire par rapport à ce
que tu disais sur cette personne que je
vais faire comparaître devant le conseil
de discipline de l'ordre des médecins
moi ce que je comprends pas c'est que
comme le disait d'ailleurs m division
tout à l'heure 6
comprends pas qu'on s'attaque aux
messages et quand il donne un message
qu'on conteste le message oui mais pour
le dialogue et pour compter pour que tu
tu veux qu'on te conteste quand même tu
étais pas pour la non non moi je suis je
sais j'aime le désaccord dans la mesure
où chacun s'accorde le crédit de ces
arguments le problème depuis le début
pour tous ceux qui contestent la pensée
unique la pensée globale la vérité
officielle et qui diverge avec elle le
problème c'est que nous on avance des
arguments et on nous répond par des
injures
donc moi j'ai envie de dire à ces gens
là donnez-nous vos arguments et
incontesté le message ne vous attaquez
plus au messager c'est insupportable
c'était c'est insupportable chaque fois
qu on diverge avec la pensée régnante
on est insulté injurié voilà cc c'est
quelque chose que je oui que je n'admets
pas et comme j'ai décidé de ne plus
l'admettre je vais faire comparaître
tout des personnes qui se sont permis ça
parce que à un moment donné il faut que
ça s'arrête c'est à dire qu'il faut au
moins faire un exemple pour que les gens
comprennent que c'est pas comme ça qu'on
discute
moi j'adore discuter j'adore pour moi
c'est très important de comprendre salle
c'est à dire que débattre mais alors
pourquoi tu voulais alors jury teriimana
permet d'en débattre
ce n'est pas combattre d'accord débattre
ce n'est pas combattre débattre c'est
chercher ensemble la vérité voilà en
opposant ses arguments alors pourquoi tu
voulais pas que les chroniqueurs
intervient de ce soir comme ça les
téléspectateurs de ça alors qu'on est
clair qu'on va revenir à ce qui s'est
passé la dernière fois que c'est avait
quitté plateau parce que voilà ils ont
ils étaient tous ceux contre toi pas du
tout 1 pourquoi l'aurait du tout mais tu
le sais bien on en a parlé oui c'est ça
c'est parce que en fait t'es où
qui est le rédacteur en chef d'émissions
qui fait un travail magnifique lui avait
dit francis tu parleras kassir x et ça
non et le saut le truc c'est moi alors
voilà donc quand tu es au m'a appelé
pour venir à l'émission j'ai dit je
voulais pas venir à l'émission d'accord
j'avais un ami qui était allé à
l'hôpital qui était en train de mourir
et qui est mort ce soir là derrière
et donc je lui ai dit j'ai pas envie de
venir l'émission ils multiplient il m'a
dit allez chez morandini ce matin tu
peux tu peux pas faire ça à cyril etc
alors je dis écoute tu dis à cyril que
je veux bien venir pour démentir mais
pas pour débattre d'accord parce que
j'aime bien débattre avec une ou deux
personnes mais à 17 comme ça n'avait pas
le courage est pas la face à l'envi
comme ça on le sait au cas et donc quand
je suis arrivé moi j'étais venu pour
démentir restait cinq minutes répondre à
deux trois questions de toi et puis j'ai
vu qu'on m'entraînais la dent que tout
était organisé pour me contraindre à
participer à un débat dans l'ue ok je ne
voulais pas participer et là je vais te
le dire en face et tulle c est une c'est
au nom de notre amitié
je me suis senti trahi par table
d'accord alors que tu n'étais pas au
courant c'est vrai et donc je tue c'est
mon point faible à moi c'est mon coeur
et toi tu sais l'affection que j'ai pour
toi c'est horrible de se sentir trahi
par un ami andy j'en connais depuis très
longtemps réel on s'en sert voilà et
voilà toujours été voilà j'ai toujours y
est toujours invitée dans les émissions
il est toujours venu il a toujours
accepté mon invitation
il sert et voilà il ya eu donc jamais
comment il ya une amitié voilà entre
francis et moi et c'est vrai que moi je
te dis francis donc on pourrait qu'on
revienne sur ce qui s'est passé juste à
un dernier mot là dessus parce qu'en
qu'il qu'on n'en parlera plus jamais
quand tu te sens trahi par un ami et moi
moi moi mon point faible c'est mon coeur
à partir de ce moment là je suis sorti
de mes gonds parce que j'étais déchiré
par le sentiment d'être trahie par un
ami maintenant tout ça est dissipée donc
je reviens voilà mais je veux revenir
aujourd'hui dans les conditions qui
était prévu la dernière est passée tout
mais je reviendrai débattre avec les
chroniqueurs avec plaisir francis juste
du c'est quand tu l'as dit c'est vrai
qu'on se connaît depuis longtemps et on
joue et qu'on voit à ce qu'a dit le
journaliste du quotidien paul là haut
tous qui est revenue sur l'incident
qu'on a vu il ya un instant
selon lui les médecins ou même gamme
essayer un traumatisme crânien que c'est
que voilà j'ai une affection pour toi et
c'est vrai que quand j'ai entendu la
version de quotidiens ça m'a fait de la
peine parce que je me suis dit c'est pas
le francis que je connaisse et voilà
qu'en 6 que que que j'apprécie depuis
des années et ça m'a peiné tu fasses ça
et je te le dis donc voilà donc tu vas
nous donne et avait un truc que tu as
cru que j'ai fait ça bah oui forcément
oui c'est ça que je compris j'écoute oui
j'ai cru en lui et je jouerai revoir ce
qui ce qu'ils ont dit regarde
francis lalanne affirme donc il ne nous
a pas frappés nous avons pris le premier
train pour rentrer à paris nous sommes
allés directement aux urgences de
l'hôpital cochin samedi dans la nuit
les médecins ont diagnostiqué pour paul
bouffard andromaque pas traumatisme
crânien une tendinite post traumatique à
l'épaule gauche à titre personnel j'ai
une entorse
poignet droit après avoir pris un coup
en tentant de m'interposer et on a
déposé plainte pour agression merci paul
et merci paul bouffard qui est parlant
merci à tous les deux alors francis
j'aimerais ce soir parce que on a eu la
version continue on l'a diffusée ici et
je le dis franchement on n'a personne
n'a remis en cause cette version mais
oui c'est ça qui était incroyable parce
que quand on voit les images on voit
bien que je n'aime pas frapper alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement
raconte-nous et que tu déjà je vais
répondre là parce que yann c'est que des
faits qui nuit aux essais que des
mensonges dont j'ai déjà répondre au
deuxième mensonge
une plainte a été déposée voilà donc
cher monsieur je vous consulte voilà
j'ai interrogé le j'ai fait interroger
le parquet d'avignon parce que c'est lui
qui est compétent un par mon avocat
donc c'est une lettre officielle que je
vais te lire cher monsieur je vous
confirme avoir interrogé ce jour le
service du parquet de monsieur le
procureur de la république d'avignon
lesquels ont confirmé qu'aucune plainte
n'a été enregistrée par le journaliste
du quotidien à votre encontre
d'accord on s'est rien passé c'est un
mensonge d'accord c'est l'un de plus
importants parmi ces donc ça veut dire
qu'une un vrai document mais c'est un
mensonge voie d'accord donc il n'y a pas
de plaintes désir d'arriver
parlons parlons du certificat médical
faut arrêter de se [ __ ] de la gueule
des gens quand il ya par exemple coups
et blessures la procédure c'est que
juste après les faits tu te rends dans
un hôpital
1 parce qu'il faut établir un lien de
causalité entre le coût et la blessure
donc tu dois faire constater tout de
suite que tu es blessé et indiquer d'où
tu viens
et d'où vient le coup donc c'est pas le
lendemain ou le surlendemain qui fait ça
parce que sinon tu peux faire n'importe
quoi tu es peut l'être mettre un coup
sur la tête chez toi pour dire c'est lui
qui m'a frappé parce qu'il est riche
qu'est donc normalement si je l'avais
frappé la procédure c'est déjà le cas il
a pris un coup déjà il est tombé par
terre ce qui dynamise qui n'est pas le
cas
déjà il a une marque déjà gars ça se
voit déjà il va crier va plus rival y
avoir des photos il ya rien de tout ça
moi j'ai une cinquantaine de témoignages
en plus de gens qui vont à tester que je
n'ai donné aucun coup mais ça c'est pas
très grave mais parlons de ce fameux
certificat médical alors tu dois te
rendre dans un hôpital
sais tu dois te rendre à lui aime j
l'unité médico-judiciaire pourquoi parce
que c'est la seule qui est habilité à
établir un lien de causalité entre le
coût et la blessure et 2
écrêté effectivement qui à coups et
blessures te faire un certificat médical
deux coups et blessures et en plus te
donner une unité c'est à dire qu'elle va
statuer sur le bien-fondé de l'it été et
sur la durée de l'itt été n'a pas ça du
tout ils sont pas du tout aller à l'ump
davignon ils sont restés tranquillement
à la fête ils ont monté tout une espèce
de mise en scène ou des semblants de
partir ils sont revenus et après j'ai
plein d'image plein de photos plein de
deux trucs filmé avec des portables on
les vois rigoler entre eux même discuté
de ce qu'ils vont faire et c'est tout
est enregistré j'ai des témoignages et
où tout ce qui s'est passé alors atteint
2 secondes et donc et dont je côtoyais
est-ce que je peux terminer et après
donc ils sont partis tranquillement il
avait aucune marque on a toutes les
images etc
et le surlendemain ils vont accrocher
alors je ne crois pas du tout je ne
crois pas du tout que qui que ce soit à
l'hôpital cochin peut s'amuser à faire
une fausse attestation ça c'est sûr il a
donc sérieuse j'espère qu'ils vont pas
s'amuser à faire ce qu'on appelle un
certificat de complaisance
parce que ça ça s'appelle un faux en
écriture publique et j'imagine pas du
tout le responsable en ce que tu as dit
allez porter plainte oui messieurs c'est
le deuxième c'est le deuxième document
que j'ai ici
donc moi je porte plainte pour l'instant
devant la la commission de déontologie
le conseil de déontologie journalistique
parce que je trouve que la conduite de
ces gens-là offense le journaliste mais
j'ai le plus grand respect pour la
profession de journaliste
mais ces gens là c'est pas des
journalistes parce que j'ai des
folliculaires sont exprimés par dont
quito apostrophé sont tous demandé non
c'est pour être filmés ou pas c'est ça
non parce que ces gens là font pas du
journalisme il faut ils font du
sensationnalisme ce sont des
folliculaires selon l'expression de
voltaire tu regarderas au dictionnaire
mais beaucoup de soi voilà non je
plaisante et dont est donc ces gens là
quand ils viennent par exemple aux
université citoyenne
ils viennent pas du tout faire un
reportage sur les citoyens français qui
se réunissent pour réfléchir ensemble
sur comment apporter une alternative
citoyenne à la politique politicienne
dont il cherche les gars qui vont
pouvoir mettre à mal en leur volant les
images en leur posant des questions les
chauffant en essayant et ensuite au
montage de trafiquer les images comme
ils l'ont fait
pour une grille de courrèges et je
connais une grille de courage il en a
fait une des fruits elle a fait une
dépression après ça c'est horrible ce
qui lui en fait ils ont complètement
trafic et les interviews ils ont tout
fait pour la pour la mettre à mal au
niveau de son image alors que c'est une
fille extraordinaire plein de courage
inject courageux l'appel - degré de
courage et donc sur gaza si tu veux ce
sont des méthodes nauséabonde qui n'ont
rien à voir avec le journalisme et que
j'entends dénoncé devant le conseil
déontologique du journalisme francis ce
soir j'aimerais vraiment que tu me
donnes ta version qu'est ce qui s'est
passé mais on veut savoir c'est tout et
sur les images d'autrefois donc ils
viennent te voir
il commet et est ce que tu es ce que tu
fais ce que tu as devient de fait le
récit est ce que ta mine patata nom à
l'un des becs non non non aucun coup n'a
été donnée mais vous n'a été donnée j'ai
tous les témoignages pour chat j'ai
toutes les preuves pour ça mais
l'épreuve et 100 sur l'image de toute
façon on voit bien je suis toujours un
mètre cinquante de gaye film il se prend
un peu les pieds dans le stand mais
qu'il reste bien droit et le gars me
retiens l'autre c'est pas moi qui le
touche 1 c'est lui qui s'agrippent qui
s'agrippent à moi par deux fois malgré
ma tendinite bon peu importe mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que bien évidemment
j'ai donné aucun coup alors je te
raconte histoire mais je suis au stand
de premières démocraties inquiète
instant de très intéressant il y avait
là un auteur que je voulais rencontrer
jean molina qui a écrit un très beau
livre qui s'appelle peut-on bâtir la
démocratie on discutait tranquillement
ensemble et la lega il arrive même pas
bonjour rien il met le micro dans le nez
et là j'ai compris
là j'ai vu ils m'ont mis devant mener
j'ai vu c'est le quotidien
donc là que j'ai dit quoi et on essaie
de me piéger bien sûr là je sais
pourquoi ils sont là je sais ce qu'ils
vont faire de ces images alors là le
problème c'est que dans ces cas là tu
vois c'est bâbord tribord qu'est ce que
je fais est ce que je le dégage tout de
suite je lui dis je veux pas parler avec
toi je sais qu'il va surfer là dessus
qui va essayer de me piéger là dessus
que le mec veut tu vas battre filmé par
ces méthodes de six ans qu'ils emploient
pour pour mettre les gens en difficulté
alors que voilà et donc je me dis
francis ne fais pas de procès
d'intention à ce garçon il n'a pas de
très bonne manière il n'a pas dit
bonjour et c'est payé s'est pas excusé
de déranger les 2,5 de s'immiscer dans
la conversation mais
voilà écoute la question qui va être
posée il fait comme ils font d'habitude
il fait semblant de me poser une
question pour me mettre à l'aise tu vois
ccc des méthodes bien connu ça
d'ailleurs on met la pression au début
pour te faire débat et après leur claque
et après tu as parlé de jean marie
bigard voilà donc moi je commençais ma
part je commence par répondre à sa
question qui était intéressante
et tout d'un coup ça n'a rien à voir
avec le sujet commence à me parler de
jean marie dans des termes que je peux
pas accepter donc qu'est ce que je fais
à ce moment là de manière très calme
avec un peu d'autorité
parce que ça nous met en colère mais
quand même je reste encore dans comment
dire dans une forme de douceur quand
même de gentillesse
je lui dis monsieur maintenant si ça
prend cette tournure je ne désire plus
parler avec vous voulez brancher votre
caméra et tu sais que normalement quand
tu diffuses l'image de quelqu'un faut
l'autorisation de diffusion et sera donc
on demande aux gens devant la caméra de
dire
j'autorise qu'on utilise mon image donc
moi je fais le contraire je dis je
n'autorise pas que usage de mon image et
voilà donc c'est pour ne pas donner
l'autorisation de diffusion donc c'est
formidable là j'ai la preuve que je n'ai
pas donné et dans la demi-heure qui a
suivi j'ai appelé d'ailleurs le
diffuseur et la maison de production
pour dire je vous confirme que je ne
vous donne pas l'autorisation de
diffusion et à ce moment là je vois
qu'il continue à filmer
donc je me lève et je n'ai qu'une seule
idée en tête c'est il efface interview
dont ils t'ont fait croire qu'il a
effacé l'interview oui en plus j'ai la
preuve de sa sagesse ils l'ont dit ils
me l'ont dit ils ont fait croire qu'ils
trient sans j'entends plus et ça c'est
des journalistes non mr francis heures
de poids aux répercussions ils ont été
un peu échaudé par ici on dit je vais me
prendre je parle pas dire quelque chose
ils ont tout simuler y compris la peur
parce que il n'y avait aucune raison
d'avoir peur puisque je n'ai pas levé la
main sur eux donc tout ça et d'ailleurs
ça se voit dans les images cette
extraordinaire ça se voit dans les
images ça se voit dans les images c'est
à dire que le gars il dit à un moment
donné quand il fait semblant d'effacer
l'image tout le monde et calmer tout le
monde est tranquille et di
mon équipe n'est plus en sécurité il se
fout de la gueule des gens ces gens là
donc de toute façon c'est pas très
important parce que moi j'ai toutes les
pièces qui prouve que ce que je dis la
vérité est qu'il dise des mensonges
mais voilà tu te rends compte francis
mais c'est grave non mais justement
parce que je vais te dire moi quand j'ai
vu le reportage du quotidien je les
revenus auraient pu après ça me fait de
la peine parce que je te dis j'ai une
profonde amitié pour toi tu le sais
voilà et je me suis dis franchement ça
me fait de la peine de voir ça qui qu'il
ait fait du mal à un mec un journaliste
et tu ne vois pas que j'ai fait du mal à
quelqu'un dit l'arrêt en voit on ne voit
pas ça sur le reportage
alors c'est très intéressant ce que tu
dis pas ce que c'est non mais je pense
comme les pleins de gens qui t'aiment
tenant bien mais alors pourquoi est ce
qu'on voit dans une image ce qu'il n'y a
pas dans une image là tu viens
d'expliquer aux gens comment marche la
télévision c'est à dire que l'on te
montre une image mais il ya un
commentaire qui explique ce que tu es
censé voir dans l'image est là à force
de dire aux gens dans cette image on ne
me voit pas frappé cette personne que
j'ai frappé sept personnes l'imaginaire
des gens va traduire le récit en réalité
et ils vont se dire j'ai vu francis
lalanne frappé sept personnes or je n'ai
pas frappé cette personne ce que
j'aurais aimé que tu me dises là
maintenant au terme de ce que je suis en
train de te dire m'a dit moi je vais te
dire c'est moi ça m'a fait de la peine
quand la grèce comme ça ça c'est marrant
alors ça ne lève se disent la vérité oui
on the lady is here
je te le dis je te dit je ne sais je lui
disais si hier je suis désolé les mecs
alors quand on va voir un mais on lui
demande avant si on le veut le film ou
pas s'il veut répondre aux questions pas
je suis désolé ça on est d'accord de
l'aiea mais c'est la loi mais on a dit
qu'on cautionnez pas si francis a tapé
le garant d'un des concours ce débat
mais on cautionne pas aussi sept jeux
vous dire moi il m'est arrivé de croiser
les équipes de quotidiens en soirée
qu'ils ont voulu me parler
bon ils ont très vite vu que voilà alors
voilà que voilà donc il survit on va
même pas simulé ils sont partis mais
alors et c'est vrai mais je
j'espère y avait plus de chance que moi
non mais je te dis bon offrant six mois
est-ce que je passe voir un peu d'eau on
n'a pas ça ici
non non juste francis je te lis parce
que moi j'ai défendu le mec de quotidien
je te dit tout tu vois je t'ai la soie
j'ai défendu le mec de copinage et
défendu les équipes de quotidiens et
j'ai dit que voilà je vois là je
trouvais que c'était inadmissible quand
ce que j'ai vu que tu aies pu frapper le
mec voilà aujourd'hui que tu me dis que
ce n'est pas le cas et c'est ce que dit
francis je vous vois tous faire des
têtes oui non oui non il y en a qui
croyaient la cli pourquoi pas les mecs
en tout cas chacun se fera son avis mais
il fallait qu'on est la version
française ce soir
voilà on a toujours les deux versions
dans cette émission on a fait la version
le quotidien on l'a passée on a tous dit
voilà ce qu'on en pense et de confiance
et de cette séquence aujourd'hui il
fallait qu'on est là en version de
francis et francis voilà te dis si ça
n'est pas le cas si l'on monte ça en
épingle et que c'est pas vrai là en
revanche ça va être très très chaud
savez dramatique ça leur rend m'a dit
alors alors je vais te dire une chose
juste si tu veux bien juste raymond sur
sa non je te francis la tendinite et
peut-être qu'il apportait la caméra
longtemps il a une tendinite ça peut
arriver c'était rien à voir là dedans
moi ce qui m'interroge c'est il est
parti à l'hôpital est obligé d'aller à
l'hôpital d'avignon il peut rentrer sur
paris et à l'hôpital c'est interdit
c'est le traumatisme crânien d'inventer
un traumatisme crânien si vous
réussissez sarr médecin qui marquait un
combat un traumatisme crânien ça c'est
très très en colère
je pense qu'on en avait on avait convenu
de quoi on est en train de déborder mais
du coup pas bien ce que fout du coup je
suis obligé c'est prenant
ban s'est mis d'accord il ya des noms
mais alors même si le défaut je vais
répondre je vais répondre à ce qu'il a
dit la procédure c'est parce à la
procédure légale c'est qu'au moment où
tu reçois un coup après les fesses tu
dois tout de suite aller à l'ump
la machine on me dit des bêtises on est
en train d'en parler la vie bah je
m'attèle juste répéter j'ai bien pensé
pourquoi le camp style mois quotidien
mentir et galoper que tu sais pas bien
de dire des bêtises c'est pas bien de
dire ce mot déjà réussi et là je au cube
et tu m'entends tu vas tomber je t'avais
dit le cupidon s'il te plait merci juste
francis s'il vous plaît merci oui bah
oui ou pour respecter les règles
merci desjardins pourquoi quotidien
montre tout à perdre je termine je
termine donc la procédure c'est que au
moment des faits pour qu'on puisse
établir un lien de causalité entre le
coût et la blessure tu dois te rendre
tout de suite dans l'hôpital le plus
proche de là où tu as été frappée ça
c'est la procédure en dehors de ça il ya
aucun certificat médical qui tient
devant la justice alors maintenant je
vais te dire quelque chose je vais donc
attaquer
je vais donc attaquer le les prétendus
journalistes
je vais également attaqué la maison de
production puisqu'elle n'a pas respecté
mon refus mangou mis dehors de donné mon
autorisation de diffusion et je vais
également attaqué la chaîne est ce que
la chaîne elle a été informée
d'accord elle a été informée que je
refusais de donné mon autorisation de
diffusion elle a diffusé quand même
voilà je suis juste plus on va pas
parler de ça toute mon enfance elle y
pose j'ai juste démenti j'aimerais te
poser une question oui est ce que tu te
rends compte
je pose à bien je suis sûr que c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose même
chez chez les gens qui n'ont rien
l'intérêt de quotidien de mentir parce
que l'assise ont menti
quel est leur intérêt alors leur intérêt
c'est que leur audimat est en train de
baisser alors que le tien monte c'est ça
leur intérêt donc leur intérêt c'est de
faire du buzz et comme ce sont des gens
tu sais les daltons les daltons la gare
d'aguas da c'était les dalton ils ceux
ci se livrèrent même pour toucher la
prime car il était encore plus bête que
méchant voilà donc l'intérêt il
ils ont certainement intérêt à faire a
essayé de mettre les gens à mal pour
faire de l'audience c'est ce qu'ils
pensent être leur intérêt la preuve que
non puisque leurs audiences baissent
mais maintenant ce qui est clair c'est
que moi la seule chose qui m'a choqué
dans cette affaire et c'est que au
moment où ces gens là sont raconté cette
histoire qui est un faux d'accord
personne n'a mis le moindre doute et
tout le monde a pris ça pour de l'argent
comptant alors que moi je suis en train
de donner ma version
et tous le nom est presque froid tout le
monde voulait choquer part à l'agression
tournon milliards grâce à des agressions
tu parles d'une agression qui n'a pas
lieu parce que il n'y a rien dans ces
images qui montrent une agression à rome
ce qui va les vendre et donc il ya un
homme en colère qui demande qu'on enlève
des images on y termine juste moi le
truc le plus important qu'il ait dit
parce que je le dis on va clôturer là
dessus parce que c'est à derna à l'est
je suis content d'ailleurs voilà soit là
francis je te le dis le tout le plus
important de tennis et est-ce qu'ils ont
porté plainte ou pas parce que s'ils ont
porté plainte
il y aura forcément une enquête et là la
vérité va sortir ben moi je porte
plainte mais eux n'ont pas porté plainte
d'accord c'est un mensonge d'accord on
va voir donc et je pense et je pense que
s'ils ont pas porté plainte justement
c'est parce qu'ils savent très bien que
tout ça n'est qu'un mensonge qui bat
très bien francis wurtz fait le tour du
sujet tumultueux avec ma version par
voie là bas je suis très content d'aller
ruth aversion ce soir voilà francis on
peut en tout cas on peut ne pas être
d'accord sur plein de choses tous les
deux mais tu sais que l'amitié comme
j'ai dis moi la mitis à duras vie et je
t'ai promis un truc ce soir à part à
l'intervention d'un oui c'est dommage
parce que c'est bien quand on donne sa
parole et qu'un engagement est pris
c'est bien qu'ils soient respectées
depuis c'était vraiment il s'est passé
quoi j'ai donc non mais ce que je veux
dire tu vois tu vois c'est ce que je ne
veux pas c'est ce que je ne voulais pas
la dernière fois
je ne suis pas venu pour faire un débat
avec 17 personnes je suis venu démentir